drugs will scare the people they scared
her yeah yeah damn you're gay it's fine
but what kind of like were you smoking
crack no I was doing math and oh okay
yeah you're doing real [__] I was doing
real [__] and they would like they would
freak them out because there's nothing
you know there's nothing they could do
yeah I'm just dwindling yeah meth is
that tasty yeah you know or you go
believe me what what's it believe me
bulimic oh I was like believe me I'm
sorry is that wrong what bulimics like
eating disorder like Karen Carpenter I
thought about doing that but I like food
too much yeah don't do that what's Karen
Carpenter she's you know wait wait
stop I don't know that's an interesting
thing you just asked what's it was
listen to me yeah look look don't look
at her
Eddie look at me man Karen Carpenter do
you know who that is no okay don't you
remember you told me you love me baby oh
oh no you don't know yet finish it then
I can't finish it
I can't finish it yeah uh the Carpenters
I can't tell people apart I was watching
hacks the other night and I'm like damn
I'm happy for Kim Cattrall and my girl
was what you're not the last year I
thought it was Kimmy girl oh my god oh
[__] apart yeah when the white
women get to a certain age I can't tell
them apart yeah yeah okay but um so
Karen Carpenter was in a folk group
called The Carpenters and she had you
could see her I mean I was a kid but um
you can see her dwindling away on TV she
was a bulimic right yeah she had
anorexia anorexia I mean and anorexia
and toward the end it was like you'd
watch her on TV and she was a drummer
right
the drumsticks were [__] thicker than
her arms oh no and it was like oh she's
gonna die and she died yeah she was I
think she might have died while she was
already recovering like her heart just
couldn't yeah it was really sad when I
see that it's so sad
what are you doing I'm showing you that
oh wow yeah yeah 83 pounds the middle
yeah the middle is when she was like
damn great teeth though
you know what I mean the teeth are
wonderful pearls yeah wow but all her
songs were very like melancholic really
like sad also they wrote
probably 10.
um amazing Banger song yeah Carpenters
yeah
dude the Carpenters I don't know yeah
yeah dudes let me ask you you don't know
let me I'm gonna raise your hand if
you've heard of this band then I'm just
going to throw you some names because I
wanted to see where you're at please I
thought I'm not shaming it yeah no no
it's cool I'm proud of my limited music
taste
or let's go um Leonard Skynyrd
Simple Man
A Simple Man Simple Man yeah is there a
song called Simple Man I don't know
oh that's wrong okay very good simple
man all right the Allman Brothers
I heard of them okay Chicago heard of
them so hard to say I'm sorry exactly
that's after they teamed up with Peter
Cetera after the cool years yeah I don't
know these guys yeah you know these guys
but you've heard of it I no I know
Chicago I don't know Peter Cetera the
Batman brothers it's Nas what's that I
made it up okay
I'm honest I didn't know the Batman
brothers
voyagers don't know them I made it up
nice doctor Journey yes okay I know them
number one Filipino like karaoke group
yeah yeah uh two hearts
I feel like two hearts is a song yeah
[__] good he's getting all of it he
knows a lot you know you know a lot it's
enough it's enough ask me some stuff now
wait does it go from Hip Hop or
something two hearts that one yeah yeah
oh it is a song yeah yeah that's why I
said it
who sings it art
one heart
r b bands for 100 you know the deal
is that a book no the part of the deal
group the group never heard of the deal
that's where baby face started the deal
I didn't know that I've never heard a
baby face you've never heard of Babyface
oh my God is it related to Old Man face
no really is there an old man face they
should have all the faces
well he just discovered Alicia Keys
three years ago yeah I didn't know
Alicia Keys until three I'm so sorry for
you
I remember when he heard he was like who
he's like babe one time he was like babe
you got to listen to this artist she's
new her name is Mary J Blige Mary J
that's a good way I like magic throw me
some more I've never heard of the deal
go ahead
Club Nouveau let's move on yeah that's
an actual Club that's not a real thing
no you got you know this group though
they everybody sampled this group
they're amazing we'll sing it yeah you
know
[Laughter]
I can't [__] sing it yeah try try nah
it's fun eat your fear all right you
know what get the lyrics bring it up
let's bring it up no you know but you
have to sing it bring the lyrics up come
on you need to instrumental with it all
right but you'll sing it with the
instrumental yeah of course yeah of
course oh they're all black that's great
let me see let me see that's great
that's great great Biden all right yeah